hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Friedrich Nietzsche in his essay on
truth and lying in an extra moral sense
tells us a sort of genealogical story
about the origin of the distinction
between truth and lying or if you like
to call it the invention of truth and
the invention as it's contrast of lying
all of this is actually going to rest on
a kind of bedrock of dissimilation and
deception in the long run for Nietzsche
but he is interested in where did this
desire for truth stem from and how did
we arrive at the point where we almost
automatically associate the true with
what is most real and we see falsehood
or lying as secondary as parasitical
upon the truth so he talks at first
about the individual wanting to preserve
himself we're talking about a state of
primitive nature and in this state the
individual will engage in dissimilation
because that is what the human intellect
has brought to the table and then he
says that at the same time because man
out of necessity and boredom also wants
to live socially in the herd well that
is wants to associate with other human
beings wants to be able to to live with
them he has to eliminate at least the
crudest forms of the war of all against
all and so there has to be some type of
what Nietzsche is gonna call here a
peaceful agreement and what is this
peaceful agreement going to take the
form of it's not a social contract or
anything quite so developed as that as a
matter of fact on a behavioral level
it's not as if there are these these
very clear norms that everyone is
following rather Nietzsche is going to
talk first and foremost about language
and so he's going to tell us here that
this peaceful agreement is going to lead
us towards truth because what truth it
will be from now on is fixed a uniformly
valid and binding terminology for things
is invented a terminology calling this
thing this sort of thing like a shirt a
shirt and everybody else calling it a
shirt instead of a Google blop or a Zuba
Zuba or whatever or if we all want to
call this a Zuba Zuba we all get on the
same page with that and so what this is
is is you could think of it as a a sheer
dividing up of the world by use of
language that everybody else sticks to
and he says the legislation of language
also enacts the first laws of truth now
why is that well the the opposition to
truth is going to be lying and the liar
as Nietzsche says is not just anybody
any old person who says something that
is untrue it's going to be things that
are in some way parasitical and
perverting the common language using it
in some sort of inordinate or selfish or
even sometimes just creative way but
there's something that turns to one's
own advantage and to the disadvantage or
the harm of other people so the liar is
somebody who doesn't just tell a story
that isn't you know factually true it's
somebody who tells a story and get
something out of it and disadvantages or
harms somebody else in the process so he
he goes down and he says the liar uses
the valid terms the words to make the
unreal appear real so the liar is able
to tell lies by using the very shared
language the very truth that we have
over here as part of this peaceful
agreement right the liar
is able to use the terminology and then
they they do they use that to make the
unreal as Nietzsche says appear real for
example there's a great example on each
is part I am rich when kore would be the
right term how do you lie in that way
you can just come straight out and use
the words you know saying I'm rich when
when you know you'd expect to see poor
or you could gussy up your house or you
could dress in a certain way or you
could behave in a certain way and say
other things that are drawing again on
this shared language this entire
conventions that provide a shared
meaning across many human
consciousnesses so he says he misuses
established conventions by arbitrary
substitutions even reversals of names
now what nietzsche points out is that we
don't really have a problem with this as
such it was a matter fact in the rest of
the essay he's gonna talk about how not
only is this part of the way truth
itself works but we actually delight in
this think about how when you're
watching a movie actually here's a
here's a great example people watch
action movies and they lose themselves
in these totally far-fetched situations
that even if it says that this is a true
story guaranteed the movie version of it
is not true on most levels right and you
can think of all these conventions that
are that are built into it like you know
somebody throws a grenade you see a big
explosion and you know fire and people
flying through the air
real grenades don't actually work like
that but that's that's the sort of set
of signs that were that we use right
then you get somebody who says that's
not realistic you know they're perfectly
fine with everything else going on in
the movie but they see something
happening like snaps somebody's neck and
they're like they couldn't snap their
neck that way they're objecting to some
sort of lying going on and they they're
doing it because they feel harmed in
sort of way so Nietzsche says that when
the person does it in a selfish and
damaging manner society is no longer
going to trust him and it excludes them
from its presence as a liar as a person
of the lie a little bit later Nietzsche
is going to say something else very very
interesting about this is this is a
little bit past the truth is a mobile
set of metaphors he's going to talk
about how we as human beings end up
allowing ourselves to lie collectively
in a style that's mandatory for everyone
and he thinks that that's what truth
itself ultimately rests on so it's not
as if there's like shining truth over
here and then the lie pops up there's
different kinds of dis simulation and
one of them is called truth and one of
them is called lie now there you notice
that I've got some other stuff under
here as well some of the things that are
left out of the picture in this this
peaceful agreement that Nietzsche thinks
are important to highlight look let's
look to on the side of lying first not
all deceptions are bad from the
perspective of the herd or if even of
the individual right there are pleasant
deceptions Nietzsche talks about you
know dreaming we put up with all sorts
of craziness in our dreams but I
mentioned film you know Nietzsche would
talk about epic poetry as a prime
example of that sort of thing there's
there's deception going on in that on
the other hand Nietzsche says we don't
value all truth because damage and
damaging and destructive truths we don't
want to hear those as a matter of fact
we're hostile to those and quite often
when somebody enunciates them they are
treated as if they are a liar when that
tends to be something rather distinct
right and so we have this very complex
picture being drawn by Nietzsche that
has to do with the invention of true
than lying this fundamental distinction
that is being made within human society
notice that you don't have this prior to
human society according to Nietzsche you
don't have this with an individual on
his or her own in the you know primitive
state of nature this is something that
happens through the development of human
culture
you